2,000 years ago, Jesus said, I'm one of the ways, one of the truths, and one
possible life. If you want to come to the mother or the father through me, that's
cool. Go forth living according to whatever feels right to you.
Okay, you got me. Clearly, Jesus didn't say that.
In fact, he said quite the opposite.
If you look in the New Testament, you will find at least 100 verses that make it
clear that Jesus is the only way to God, the only way to experience an eternal
relationship with the Father. Truth is vitally important because eternity
is at stake. Now philosophers use a term that seems fancy but I think you'll find
it's kind of common sense what's called the correspondence theory of truth.
And all this means is you have essentially a belief this is an idea
you hold about the world but then you have the world over here this is reality
now truth is not a belief truth is not reality truth is when your
belief matches up with reality that's what we mean by true
have you ever noticed how much you base your entire life down the details the daily
decisions on what you think is true
What if somebody says it's cold outside?
How do you check whether that is true or whether that's false?
Well, you can look at a weather app and see what information it gives you.
Or you could actually walk outside and you could see it for yourself.
If it is cold outside, then your belief is true.
If it's not cold outside, then the belief is false.
We do this with historical issues such as the claim that Jesus rose from the grave
and we do this with scientific matters such as the claim or the belief that the
universe had a beginning we actually do this on all sorts of issues we hold a
variety of beliefs and then we go see if the world is the way we take it to be if
our beliefs match up it's true if our beliefs don't it's false but remember to keep
this in mind our beliefs don't create reality but rather our beliefs should reflect
reality you might be thinking wait a minute when it comes to religious claims can't
you have your beliefs and I have mine aren't your beliefs true for you but my
religious beliefs true for me not too long ago my father was speaking at a
leadership event for about 400 high school students and in his session my dad
decided to walk out into the audience and interact with the students and he started
by asking a simple question to a student that was there he said do you think the
Bible is true and the student jumped in he goes yes I think the Bible's true my dad
said you think it's scientifically and historically accurate in everything it
teaches that we properly understand the student looked back instantly said of course
you know my dad asked this simple question back he said why the student had no
answer in fact my dad went around the room and not a single student had a thoughtful
answer to why he or she believed that the Bible is true.
Well, the session was done and my dad was walking towards the back of the auditorium
and this student comes running up to my father.
He goes, Josh, Josh, I know the answer.
I know why the Bible's true. My dad said great, why is the Bible true?
He looks at my father and he says the Bible is true because I believe it.
My dad said wait a minute, the Bible's true because you believe it?
What about a Quran and a Muslim who believes the Quran?
This student looked my dad right back in the eyes and he said, If a Muslim believes
the Quran is true then the Quran is true for him.
Now my dad gave back to this student a memorable and powerful response.
He said here's the difference between me and you.
You think the Bible is true because you believe it.
But I believe the Bible because I think it is true.
you see nothing is true or false because we believe it our beliefs don't change
reality but given how important truth is let's hope that our beliefs
match up with the reality we've been talking about why truth is important but let me
share a story about my mom to help make this point really sink in so my mom has come
a long ways with technology but she honestly used to be afraid of anything
technologically speaking in fact when my mom gets up the new technology she would
read the instructions letter by letter and followed as best as she can well she got
a computer up pops something that says close all windows
well my mom decides to and I think you see where this is going get up from her
chair walk around the house and close all the windows in the house
when she told the story obviously a little bit embarrassed we realize that truth has
consequences in this case embarrassment confusion but in many cases confusing truth
can lead to devastating consequences
but when we know truth we're set free so we see a computer it's created
and designed to function a certain way when we use it according to its design then
we're set free we can accomplish things.
But when we don't know its design, like in the story with my mom, what happens?
Confusion, frustration and sometimes significant consequences.
I think one of the greatest lies and confusions of our age deals with the question
of what is freedom. Have you ever thought in your life what is real freedom?
When I ask students to define freedom typically they'll say to me freedom is when
you can do whatever you want to do as long as nobody is telling you how to
live your life. If it feels good, do it and you're free.
Friends, that's not freedom. Living according to whatever feels good is going to
enslave you to your passions. Real freedom is when we embrace God's
design for our life which is to love him and to love other people.
That's why Jesus said in John chapter three that if we live according to his design
for our life that we live in truth our works will be made known to the world
real freedom is not living according to whatever we think is right but embracing
God's design for our life real freedom is when we live in light of truth.